[Music]
Guardian waits patiently as cloud my
scepter push-up major champions
you thank you I don't really have much
words to say as you know I'm not crying
you're crying thought you know for me he
goes down as one of the best players
North America has ever produced the best
offer that North America has ever ever
produced trying some different [ __ ] out
I'd be a little interested
[Music]
hey what what Solomon along
nice
hello everyone long time no see it is
official I have joined t1 as a
professional valorem player and once
again I will be competing on the field
skadoodle is a North American csgo
legend still two more on the site here
12 seconds now on the clocks at dural
getting one big kill device down six
seconds left and skip total he may have
just done of a noscope in 2018 he
brought glory to na winning the region
its first and only major to date with
cloud 9 Guardian waits patiently as
cloud biceps to push up
[Applause]
join
[Applause]
major champions
[Applause]
skoo doodle popped off against faze clan
in the finals in what's arguably his
best performance of his career with some
of his issues with it with the
communication stories that we'd heard
with with the lack of wanting to like
take over games and lack of like desire
to be that forceful superstar who could
just will his team to victory at times
he did both of those things you know in
Boston culminates in an MVP and it
culminates in a trophy and it's it's the
capstone and that's got to be the
biggest thing you look at when you think
of his legacy in his career but after
hitting the highest point you can reach
in competitive csgo skadoodle
experienced the lows but overall
definitely closes out the round in their
favor filled and now it's gonna go down
to Paul Yi 22 to 19 and G to knockout
cloud nine here the major after winning
the major at the beginning of the year
cloud nines performance dropped off a
cliff and it looked like skadoodle
needed a break he wanted out I'm pretty
sure at least wanted to take some kind
of a break and the announcement was made
but then you had Stewie leave and then
you had Tareq leave and then scoodle is
just there and he's he knows he can't
just leave them high and dry and he
sticks around even though he's not
motivated so in October 2018 a burnt-out
scoff finally took a break from pro play
and stepped away from cloud 9 's active
roster after a while results and
traveling and stuff get kind of kind of
wear you down a little bit and for me
personally now is a good time for me to
take a break you know I've been playing
the team for a long time doing kind of
the same thing I've been doing for a few
years now
it's just a little bit of everything
kind of coming down on my head at once
so you know it's it's good to just take
a step back and really look at where you
are and kind of just you know support
the team and however I can he shifted
gears and took his talent to the world
of streaming skadoodle reunited with his
old teammate shroud and the deal were
deadly and whatever shooter they decided
to play
[Music]
good but in 2020 a new game caught
skadoodle zai a first person shooter
similar to see us go but just different
enough to set itself apart project a is
our character based tactical shooter
it's competitive
it has precise gunplay it's set on a
beautiful near future earth and it has a
lethal cast of characters each with
their own unique abilities even in the
closed beta the game looked to become a
hit everyone was playing riots new
shooter at the end of his csgo career
scar lost that fire he needed in order
to compete at the highest level valor
reignited that flame so skadoodle joined
a team but not just any team he joined
t1 one of the most successful
organizations in the history of eSports
hello everyone
long time no see it is official I have
joined t1 as a professional valor and
player and once again I will be
competing on the field for skadoodle
joining t1 doesn't just mark a return to
pro play it's a reunion with old
teammates AZK and brats who he famously
played with on iBUYPOWER back in the day
spoken with t1 a lot and their visions
aligned with mine we both want to win
big we both want to lift big trophies
you know obviously become the best team
in valent also i mean it really helps to
have a Zeke and Brax on the team already
and you know you guys most of you have
known I've already played with them
before and so our natural team chem is
already there I've meshed with them
before fantastic players and
very exciting to meet up with them once
again and to compete and while he only
joined T one a few weeks ago they've
already picked up their first tournament
win at the North American twitch rivals
Bauer launched tournament and the guide
to clutch t1 the win in the final round
well it was none other than skadoodle
five second seal five second seal
feeling I'm gonna pee Kevin Kevin both
both both of it
[Music]
there's still a lot of questions
surrounding scoodles future and Valerie
both the eSports scene and the game
still need some work and he'll he hasn't
even decided what role he's gonna be
playing on this new team thinking about
picking up the OP again I know I want to
be a riflery cuz I feel like as a writer
you can be a lot more mobile and in the
action but then again it's uh as an off
you know getting those entries and
playing retake is gonna be pretty big in
this game I feel like and even just one
frag could be the difference depending
on who you take down which agent you
take down I mean you could take down
their stage and then no longer have a
free rez or you take down their
brimstone and they can't they can't use
their own anymore you know whoever you
know upping is important but with the
backing of any sports giant and t1 and
familiar teammates around him skadoodle
has a chance to make this second pro
career something special thanks for
watching if you want more content like
this hit the sub button and bring that
notification bell for unique bite-sized
videos you won't find anywhere else hit
up our Instagram Twitter and Facebook
pages